a 2016 meeting involving Donald Trump
jr. and a Russian lawyer is giving a new
explanation from President Trump in a
tweet yesterday defending his son the
president said this was a meeting to get
information on an opponent totally legal
and done all the time in politics and it
went nowhere I did not know about it
when the meeting was first revealed a
year ago Trump jr. said the participants
primarily discussed a program about the
adoption of Russian children a day later
from jr. said the Russian lawyer offered
vague ambiguous information that
Russians were helping Hillary Clinton
two days after that Trump jr. released
emails showing he was offered damaging
information on Clinton when the
president was asked about the meeting he
downplayed the potential political value
most people would have taken that
meeting
it's called opposition research guess
they talked about as I see it they
talked about adoption and some things
adoption wasn't even a part of the
campaign two months ago the president's
attorney Jay Sekulow ciccolo rather
acknowledged mr. Trump dictated the
initial statement referring to adoption
now he had denied that the president was
involved in the meeting and the stories
about it are a big part of the special
counsels Russia's investigation Paula
Reid is in Alexandria Virginia covering
the trial of former Trump campaign
Chairman Paul Manafort
so Paula before we take a look ahead to
week two of the metaphor case is the
president right when he says that the
Trump Tower meeting was quote totally
legal and how big of a deal is this how
important is it what a special counsel
Robert Muller it's incredibly important
he is looking at the Trump Tower meeting
as one of a pattern of meetings between
Trump campaign officials and Russian
operatives u.s. campaigns cannot
coordinate or receive any support from
foreign nationals so the question is was
it just a meeting or was this part of a
larger effort to coordinate this a
release of information about the
opponent or in any way meddle in the
election we know the special counsel has
already church over a dozen Russians
conspiring to meddle in our elections so
the question now for these investigators
is did anyone in the Trump campaign
participate now there is some other
legal exposure for Donald Trump jr. he
has not yet been interviewed by special
counsel that should concern him his
father and anyone around him because
typically you're just a witness if
you're just offering evidence you were
brought in much earlier in an
investigation but if he is interviewed
he needs to make sure that he tells the
truth because clearly there's a lot of
different versions about what happened
and while it's not a crime to release a
false press release it is a crime to lie
to the FBI there are also questions
about possible perjury testified before
Congress his father didn't know about
the Trump Tower meeting but if that
turns out not to be true that's another
possible exposure for him all right day
five of Paul Manafort trial and tax
evasion and bank fraud charges what are
you expecting this upcoming week of
testimony this is going to be a big week
at a prosecution says they should be
able to wrap up their case by the end of
the week they will continue to urge this
jury to follow the money
now last week the star piece of evidence
was this fifteen thousand dollar ostrich
coat that sort of came to symbolize
manna for taste in luxury but this week
it's gonna be all about his former
business associate at deputy campaign
Chairman Richard gates he is the star
prosecution witness and of course he
agreed to testify against manna port in
exchange for leniency in his own
criminal case
alright Paula thank you very much